i was uh very lucky to be here during
the nba finals watch those games do the
shows with you guys i will for always
associate that
finals with this show it holds a special
place in my heart
and it was amazing to have marcus
johnson calling the show the day after
he was shirtless
rolling through the streets of milwaukee
like
j.r smith i mean marcus johnson the
five-time all-star
raymond from white men can't jump he's
got the guns out
shirtless i was thinking like what if
that was my
dad like how would i feel how do i feel
if i looked on twitter and i saw my dad
shirtless in a championship parade so i
thought we'd get someone on the show who
could answer that question
so joining us right now the king of nba
twitter at king josiah 54
josiah johnson who watched his dad
shirtless celebrate the milwaukee bucks
win what was that like for you
to see the big guy do that first of all
what's going on legends
what's up legend what's he's looking
real good out there he's like 260 we
might have to get him tested for hda
though i don't know you know if he was
in the olympics right now he might get
banned
just based on what's going on because
he's looking he looking too good for 65
so something's got to be up
is he just on one when he's out there
the whole time what was that like
because you were out there for a game
yeah
so we went out there for game three uh
me him my older brother chris
and uh after that point i flew back to
home the next day and he was gonna fly
back too but he had such a good good
time game three
he was like now i'm gonna stay for game
four so ended up staying for game four
hung out with kareem dave chappelle that
whole crew that had a legendary group
frodo
with all type 11 legends even kendrick
perkins was in the mix over there
so then he was like man you know what
i'm gonna go back for game six too i
went back for game six obviously they
won the championship and then you know
the city of milwaukee just honestly
really really is a
amazing city they embrace him and they
they treat him so well so
at the jeep form he was matched i'm
saying funny thing he doesn't drink he's
been soaked since like 2000 so
you know he was out there just high on
like you know turning up with the crew
so
to see him out there shirtless flex and
doing all that great stuff was amazing
incredible it's so great it's so great
joe oh i got a six pack
it looks awesome it looks incredible joe
let me ask you real quick before we get
in this interview you know as
most young men we get to a point in life
where we look at our dad and we grow up
a little when we try to buck up a little
bit like yeah i think i might
try you did you ever reach that point
with your dad and i'm hoping you didn't
but did you ever reach that point where
you were like
let me see if i could take the old man i
mean growing up we used to hear all
these stories about how great our dad
was
we've seen the jordan picture in north
carolina with his poster on the wall
but he had a janky hip and he had a neck
injury which effectively ruined his pro
career he was able to bounce back from
that and play a little bit more with the
warriors
and overseas but for most of my life i
just thought my dad was watched because
when i was like 13 14 i was giving a
bucket
giving him that work one-on-one
thankfully thankfully uh his parents and
him did a great job of just documenting
all his game so we had a bunch of
debaters and vhs so i started going
through him one day so i'm giving you
know everybody in the league buck is dr
j he block kareem shot
which he's got on his phone now remember
lebron came and played at ucla
he pulled lebron aside put up that clip
and blocking kareem this is so lebron he
was certified but
seeing him now you know it just and the
way he's going obviously being a six-man
hall of fame finally didn't get in last
year but we're super optimistic and
hopefully they'll be able to make that
push and get on through
you know seeing his game get the respect
and love he deserves some guys like
lebron and giannis and everybody in the
league
and being you know not be our first
point forward but the creator of the
turn point forward
is a tremendous thing especially the way
the game has evolved with so many guys
like lebron occupying that role now
at king josiah 54 josiah johnson joins
the show
you know him from out of pocket wave tv
buckets he's a legend he was the writer
on mostly football the show i did with
martellus bennett which
as you can imagine only lasted one
season
we're happy to have him on the show
we're happy to have him on a day like
today
when we as basketball fans are blessed
with
news like andre drummond will be backing
up joel embiid when you
find out that information for what you
do on twitter
creating content around what's happening
in the world of basketball
do you are you salivating like that's
just uh that's just a layup for you
isn't it
ben i used to it used to be a layup i'm
trying to change my life there's a lot
of
a negativity and bitterness on twitter
so i'm trying to be more positive and
uplifting
occasionally i'll give my jokes in here
or there but i always say like this you
know when i was first starting i was
able to do a lot of that stuff because i
didn't have to worry about seeing these
guys on the streets
but now guys like like kd steph lebron
follow me
and love my stuff so i got to be super
super cognizant of that
every time i post because as you see kd
on twitter is a is a menace so i don't
ever want to be
in his crosshairs or end up on the wrong
side of a kd tweet so i just try to keep
it real respectful now but occasionally
i got to get my jokes in the digging a
little bit
there was definitely a lot of news
yesterday and today that that was worthy
of some attention so
these moments obviously with the season
now over this is kind of like the last
dance the last hurrah to get these jokes
off before the new calendar
uh basketball season i appreciate your
positive attitude putting good energy
out into the world making people laugh
bringing joy but i i do want to lower
the mood just for a moment and and send
my condolences for your loss i know
you're grieving that alex caruso is no
longer a member of the lakers
it was a sad day in the city of los
angeles yesterday as you guys know alex
caruso honorary light-skinned
embraced in all parts and corners of los
angeles you know he himself said he
he does he can't go to the cookout but
he can get it to go play to be within
150 yards of any kick out in l.a
uh you know but los angeles lakers fans
love what he does our championship to
the city and
getting really bad you never want to
stand in the way of a man in the back
the bulls got a great defender just a
high iq guy that's going to bring a lot
of value to that squad
along with lonzo ball a personal
favorite of mine you know
an instrumental member of the ball
family and exactly being a former ucla
brewing i'm super excited for what
chicago did and
they got a good one i'm a little sad
that i saw reports that the lakers
didn't even try to
you know match the offer whatsoever they
had caruso's bird where i can kind of
just let him off
but hey you know he's getting that
delivered over back hopefully he'll have
a better result on the court than delhi
did
what color carmelo anthony lakers jersey
should i get joe
i would say go with that uh that powder
powder blue that powder blue
you know definitely you know we mellow
be great look you know if we got room
i'm yelling inside mellow that's the
whole that's the motto
i know if we get that crew together the
browns putting together the expendables
you know as usual in these situations a
lot of people taking shots at him
similar to what they did
you know in 2020 before the bubble oh he
thinks he's the gm he thinks he's this
he thinks he's that
then we're hosting the trophy in the
hardest championship in nba history
so we don't have time for that right now
they're saying we're watching we're a
team of just full
full of old dudes but when we won the
ship in 2022 they'll say with the super
team so you know how the game goes and
the goal the post move
what happens to your timeline when you
get a retweet from lebron
oh it's uh you know that was that was a
momentous day june 10th uh 2021 you know
went into the uh what is it the next
game you know just
average day for me i was going to get
these flares out get this heat off ended
up putting up a tweet
and you know not only from the coastline
but we went back and forth like three or
four times and actually had an
interaction
so you know from that moment though i
knew i was going to get a lot of hate
and bitterness from the mediocre humans
who
haven't been co-signed and called the
goat by their goat it's just a you know
a tremendous feeling i think
it's for me it kind of you know my
personal life it understood my
professional intuition i probably
greatest moment in my twitter history
but then i got to build upon that
because you know one is so close to none
so i need more coastlines now
i need more bags i need everybody to get
in line and really break bread
josiah johnson joins the show joe what's
up
who's the next uh guy you're looking for
to hit you with that retweet
um you know probably obama you know
somebody on that level
our lord and savior jesus christ will be
nice just you know at this point once
you get with lebron
it's like you know oprah i've obviously
gotten the shout out from ava duvernay
who i've done a lot of work with it and
worked on her show so
just to see the way that people are
getting behind the movie really just
getting over with it has been great to
see and brockman i don't know if you
remember but
i'm supposed to take your money at some
point supposed to have a shooting
contest i've been putting their work
i've lost about 85 pounds with the
pandemic
for back buttery back buttery so we need
to go ahead and do it on the show
rich can be there ben could be there
whatever you want to do i'm coming to
take your bread and that is what it is
what are we putting on it are we putting
on a case of uh tom brady birthday
kombucha i mean these things weren't
cheap at everyone today
we could put a big face dollar bill on
it
[Laughter]
josiah johnson joins the show anytime
joe
the casual the casual uh name drop of
ava duvernay we really appreciate
because joe's working closely with her
on this colin kaepernick series
where are we at with the cap series and
what are audiences going to expect from
it
you know i'm hoping that they make an
announcement at some point soon uh when
the show is gonna debut so i can really
raise these bags even higher but getting
the opportunity to work with ava
michael starberry who was the showroom
on the show and i was a co-creator of
legends of chamberlain heights with
myself and also
obviously being able to just be in the
presence of colin kaepernick just an
amazing human being and
just had such an amazing life and
everything he's done it continues to do
to raise awareness about social
injustice and all the other things going
on
and it's crazy to me now to seeing all
the stuff going on in the nfl with guys
not wanting to get vaccinated and do
simple things
and this is the way they respond to that
versus the way they responded to a man
who decided to
do a peaceful protest to raise awareness
for social injustice and optical
still hasn't gotten back in the nfl as a
result of that but i think this show is
really gonna
spotlight and highlight just his life
how he became the man who he is and it's
gonna be a really really unique
look at his life in his high school life
and just kind of how he grew
in the seas they were playing it early
on that that sprouted out he once became
an adult in the nfl
and you know did the things that he
needed to do you know i
i'm very lucky to consider you a friend
but i'm a fan
first it's how i first got familiar with
your work and to see you now
telling sports stories across social
media to make people laugh
and then working with someone like avery
duvernay and a story of telling a colin
kaepernick's life to make people think
it's truly remarkable man i'm super
happy for you and proud of you when did
you realize that sports storytelling
was your thing and something you were
going to be a part of uh probably in the
early 2000s when i was bench warming at
ucla
uh you know anybody who could pull on my
face and see i wasn't the uh
the most decorated glorified basketball
player but you know on the bench we had
to really entertain ourselves for hours
during games you know to fight the
depression
use comedy as a coping mechanism so
being in the locker room with guys like
trevor ariza jordan farmer
earl watson matt barnes jason capono
just a you know cavalcade of just
legends you had to be able to hold your
own
keep up and keep the mood light keep
guys you know really focus on the season
so
at that point and then afterwards
working at places like nfl network with
brock where we first crossed path
obviously being able to work on mostly
football with yourself we got to do a
lot of
crazy stuff and they almost couldn't
bring the show back under what we did i
think we uh
we offended a lot of people but we
raised the bar in terms of sports and
comedy so
for me everybody kind of looked at the
social stuff he's like oh he's a twitter
guy and it's like really twitter is
kinda
the least of the the things that i do
professionally the one that keeps me the
most engaged and
it's more a hobby than anything so you
know i don't look at his work it's just
you know my job to entertain people keep
the mood like especially with the
pandemic that we've dealt with in a
still dealing with so people know they
can come to my
page they can you know take a load off
just get some good comedy you're not
going to see me out there
bickering about per and all that other
stuff that we got a lot of twitter gms
and experts who don't get a
single check from any nba team but love
to be on there try to flex will do
i just like to keep the mood light and
you know keep people entertained
you mentioned mostly football the show
we got to work on together
you wrote a skit that somehow had me
doing a really bad baker mayfield i had
the full outfit on
like the mustache at the time you
remember that that was a weird one i
don't remember the premise of it
i think i think we used to have a great
time with those skits basically we
didn't have a huge budget to do them so
we would literally go to the t-shirt
t-shirt store down the street get a a
baker's jersey made
throw you guys in to give you the
headband let you go run wild with it and
uh
no just a great time obviously that show
didn't really get the respect and love
that it deserved and i look now even at
what that show was able to do and you
know we had a great time obviously
working with martellus bennett who's one
of the most brilliant
human beings on the planet obviously so
much more than a football player and
doing such a
amazing stuff in his career yourself and
obviously james davis
another close friend of mine me and
james actually went to junior high
school together so one of the the top
comedians in the game
but you know we're gonna get the love we
deserve at some point hopefully we get a
banner
hopefully we get our jerseys hung in the
raptors at yahoo sports and complex in
both offices
for beverly hills new york sunnyvale and
la offices and you know
at some point get the love that we
deserve he said sunnyvale uh you
you look at comedy differently when
you're talking about the nfl compared to
the nba
is there a different language you speak
when finding the jokes in each sport
well yeah i mean the nfl those are a lot
bigger and tougher so i got to be super
super mindful of it because you know
if those guys pull up on me on the
street you know i'm 6 8 285 but i really
like my hands on that nfl level so
you know if those guys see me on the
streets it becomes problematic in the
situation i always got to be super super
respectful of it and also they wear
helmets so it's hard to tell what a lot
of those guys look like so you just
never know i never want to get ambushed
or anything like that so
be respectful but also just you know
find a way to infuse the humor and come
into the sport
josiah getting back to the world of
basketball you excited for some of the
moves the clippers are going to make
this offseason where do you see clipper
nation heading into free agency
i have no concern for the clippers band
as you know it's lebron james lakers
obviously i was a former clippers fan
until lebron came to the lakers i
swore full of leaders to lebron in 2003
when he ascended from the heavens into
the nba
uh but you know if they can get kawhi
back obviously which it looks like it's
going to happen
i think you know he's going to need a
year to recover but hoping that he's in
good health and
i'm not one of those type of people that
wants to see la teams down i love the
city
so i would love to see you know the
dodgers the rams
the clippers the lakers all perform well
the chargers haven't embraced them
they're still san diego team they just
they just play city
they're not they're not fully embraced
yet they got to pull up the roscoe or
something to get that full
full stampage but you know you want the
teams to be good i would love to see a
western conference finals with the
lakers and clippers and obviously lebron
just smacked them but you want the teams
to be successful i don't want i don't
want the clippers to be nasty then
everybody beats him and then when the
lakers do it's not a big deal we want
that
to really sting and burn and you know
rocking with lebron has been a
tremendous tremendous ride and trying to
get championship number five obviously
he's already the goat there's no debate
about that
as you guys are fully aware no but we
really just want to cement that goat
stamp on lebron james
i will say look i i josiah was the first
person i met
at my first day at nfl network okay i
shadowed him
he taught me how to cut highlights and
kind of do the thing
at nfl network so his love for lebron
i've seen it it's real it's not an act
okay he's been talking about lebron is
the goat
as far back as i've known him so that's
12 years okay
but joe i saw in a picture that you
posted recently one of your kids was
wearing a giannis jersey like what's up
with that do they have favorite players
other than lebron
well brockman as you know my dad works
for the bucks i do a lot of bucks
pandering uh the city
emilia wonke has been amazing to me and
my family pulled up to game three
got major love we were turnt up at the
jockey club with the big shrimps and all
you all you can
drink beverages and all you can eat
shaking hands hob knobbing hanging out
with legends like tj out of shoulder
from if uh from twitter
kiki vanderwei all types of always major
love especially for young as well my dad
has a great relationship with jonas it
just is just so high on him as a human
being
and to be able to see his development
over the past few years and to see him
turn into a champion
to see him kind of get the slanders that
he's got to be honest doesn't have a bad
giannis can't do this giannis can't do
that now john is the world champion
finals mvp
looking to repeat so we've got to keep
the kids you know we're not involved in
this house we show a lot of love
internationally we respect guys
and uh had to get the honors jersey for
the youngsters got alonzo
lonzo lakers throwback jersey too and i
did a pop for the wizards so they sent
me some westbrook throwback so i'm super
appreciative of them as well
but we'll take whatever jersey we can
get we really want to we're trying to
bring those
that throwback day back you know we're
fabulous and then from the early 2000s
really just have those 5x
5x back jerseys really in the move is
yadas the best player in the league now
um the best player not named lebron
james i would definitely give him that
that title and distinction
but look giannis has a very compelling
case for that argument you know you can
do that when you win a championship you
win a finals mvp
you went head to head with kevin de
grant durant obviously the the nether
have a full squad but that doesn't
matter because i'm i'm hearing the same
chatter about the lakers who
were literally a d injury away from from
winning another championship so the game
is the game as i said on the wire and uh
you gotta you got to play with what you
have
giannis and the bucks went out there and
did it you know they say he doesn't have
a true superstar but i think chris
middleton really came into his own
drew holiday obviously ucla guy was kind
of playing a little wishy washy earlier
in the playoffs but came through and
now helping to lead team usa hopefully
to a goal so
they've got a super strong squad bobby
porter's obviously just the living
legend
you know coming back so i'm i don't know
if they're going to be able to repeat if
the lakers are healthy but i'm
looking forward to that lakers bucks
2022 finals because i'll
probably have more love in milwaukee
than la but i will be at multiple games
hey last thing joe before we let you go
are there rumors true that your co-host
zach on out of pocket is going to start
wearing mesh shirts now that russell
westbrook's a laker is that true
exactly exactly that shirt nipple rings
uh you know the whole gamut you're gonna
get some more tattoos
you know of just random random meanings
but you know super super
super great to work with him on out of
pocket and thankful to the folks away
for giving us a look and letting us
really go do the show that we want to
and
talk as wild and reckless as we want it
and do do things
but you know you know we're going to
really get it in the mess shirts might
be in man i think westbrook you might
have to crop tops you might have all
types of just fashion statements being
made
and i'm here for it i love russ
obviously russell ucla got his own rust
a long time and
for me it's really troublesome to see
the slander that he's received
throughout his career
just knowing how much of an amazing
human being is i think anybody who
really knows
russell westbrook story would be just
you know have no reason to hate on the
guy like the guys just you know grew up
in l.a
the things that he's done the things
that he's seen being an underdog
you know not being a highly titled
recruit coming out of high school and
turning himself
into one of the greatest players i would
say nba history the only player to
average a triple double in multiple
seasons
obviously he's done it four times and
russell westbrook has made triple
doubles essentially look like nothing
now you got people that
that tree triple doubles would used to
be this amazing untouchable thing now
just like oh no big deal because
westbrook did it but
i think he's going to fall in line with
the lakers i think lebron and nady were
smart for bringing them in
and if you're a lakers man you should be
super excited to have russell westbrook
in the city along with trevor reese a
guy played with at ucla trevor
trevor might be a little old but he's
been chilling the past few years so he's
gonna really come out here and get it
really do it put on for the city hoop
masters legend trevor ariza
back in the building i'm super stoked
for the crew i love the energy joe
you're so positive man it's infectious
like the dj khaled of nba twitter
i love it keep it positive man out here
doing it good stuff joe thank you for uh
spending some time and i hope uh zach
takes you up on those mesh shirts and
nipper rings that'll be good for the pod
are you gentlemen stay black and stay
blessed always joe always
messiah johnson king josiah 54.
i'm a legend hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here